Y por eso creo que tiene sentido que busquemos maneras
de mitigar ese impacto.
Y necesitamos investigaciones para lograrlo.
Necesitamos entender la ciencia que hay detrás.
Me he percatado de que hay un tema que se desarrolla en TED,
"el miedo contra la esperanza",
o "la creatividad contra la precaución".
Y claro, necesitamos de todo ello.
Así que no hay soluciones mágicas.
Ciertamente esta no lo es.
Pero necesitamos que la ciencia nos dé opciones,
que impacten en nuestra creatividad y precaución.
Soy optimista respecto a nuestro futuro.
No es que sea optimista porque nuestros problemas sean pequeños
sino porque creo que nuestra capacidad para lidiar con nuestros problemas
es mucho más grande de lo que imaginamos.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
Esta charla desató mucha controversia en TED2017,
los invitamos a leer otras opiniones en línea.